if you watch enough cable news you start
to realize there are a handful of
bankable segments these are segments
that describe some outrageous behavior
which the media presents as shocking
they'll all pretend to be very concerned
by it but in fact this Behavior happens
all the time and the media loves it when
it happens because it lets them fill
airtime on slow news days especially
there's maybe no more obvious example of
this phenomenon than so-called protests
by climate activist every time
purple-haired climate nuts deface a
historic work of art or throw paint on
the side of a building
it's usually good for a quick two-minute
segment on cable news and a few viral
posts on social media why are those
theater kids so upset with the monolisa
befuddled panelists will ask themselves
why are the Oberlin sophomores at the
Sunrise movement surrounding that
politician who's trying to get to his
car they sure are crazy this kind of
thing happens constantly at this point
you only kind of roll your eyes when you
see it and you've been seeing a lot of
it lately a few days ago for example
climate activists as we talked about on
the show smashed the uh glass protecting
Velasquez's Venus painting in London's
National Gallery and before that just a
few weeks ago protesters glued
themselves to signs in the national
museum of natural history in Washington
and there are many many more examples
but the point is these climate lunatics
act out uh deface public property that
sort of thing all the time and then
there's some angry news segments about
it and then everybody moves on this is
the familiar cycle radicals who are
fixated on climate change almost all of
whom are we can assume pretty mentally
ill are treated as nuisances in fact you
know many times people seem to pity them
because they obviously have no idea what
they're talking about they're very
confused nor do they remotely understand
how to persuade others to join their
cause because they're just alienating
people all the time and they're
generally hopelessly deluded but the
truth which nobody wants to say out loud
for some reason is that these climate
activists are not simply nuisances they
are instead in many cases a mortal
threat to sane people everywhere they
are enemies of civilization who endanger
the lives of Innocents if you don't
believe that or if you think it sounds
too extreme consider this story from 24
hours ago which corporate media in the
United States has not covered at all as
a telegraph reported the group just stop
oil gathered at London's Waterloo Bridge
where they blocked an ambulance carrying
a patient with a life or death
injury uh life or death injury that's
quotes by the way it's what we're being
told by officials here's what that
looked
like
that's good so you see them just kind of
sitting there you see them sitting there
you also see the police uh sort of
casually standing there and taking their
time getting the people off the street
now according to the telegraph in this
episode quote an ambulance arrived with
blue lights and Sirens but was held up
in traffic for 10 minutes the driver of
the ambulance told the telegraph I'm
responding to a life and death emergency
I'm going to pick up a team from gu's
hospital to save someone's life at
another hospital but I can't get through
so even though they took this kind of
lacad isical approach and everyone's
just sitting around the cops are taking
their time there's actually some urgency
to this situation or at least there
should be apparently this ambulance
driver was transporting a patient whose
lungs had stopped working he needed
urgent medical attention so as a
telegraph reported the ambulance driver
quote please with police officers to let
him through on multiple occasions as he
became increasingly angry officers said
they were working to let him through as
quickly as they could as activists lay
on the ground in this case as far as I
can tell the patient in the ambulance
survived thankfully but ask yourself
this question why haven't you heard this
story how many reports have you heard
about climate activists tossing paint in
museums why is the media reporting about
that and not the people these climate
activists nearly killed it's worth
answering that question especially since
unfortunately people have died during
and perhaps because of these unhinged
climate uh protests here's one example
which also received basically zero
attention from our media a year ago this
month a psychist in Berlin died after
climate activists prevented her from
getting to the hospital as the BBC
reported the 44-year-old woman was hit
by a concrete truck and um a cement
truck and then quote the fire service
says a specialist rescue vehicle was
delayed by traffic because of a climate
protest held by a group called last
generation a senior green party uh
figure condemned the climate protest
after the woman's death saying quote
anyone who risks the health and life of
others loses all legitimacy and also
harms the climate movement itself now
what's left unset here and what really
needs to be said is that anyone who
blocks traffic is risking the health in
life of others they are guilty of
reckless endangerment at a minimum and
murder if somebody dies as a result of
their little
blockade it is a little different
morally from you know someone who goes
outside and starts firing a gun into the
at random targets now maybe they won't
hit anyone maybe they aren't trying to
hit anybody but they are doing something
incredibly Reckless with total disregard
for the damage it may cause but that's
not how these people are being treated
instead with very few exceptions police
officers are allowing climate activists
to blockade roads with total
impunity that's been happening in Panama
for the past three weeks as a Daily Mail
reports quote roadblocks set up by
protesters have caused up to $80 million
in Daily losses to businesses according
to Panama's Association of company
Executives with closed with schools
closed Nationwide for over a week and
more than 150,000 medical appointments
missed these protesters are blocking a
uh major thoroughfare the Pan American
Highway roughly 50 miles west of Panama
City the point of this protest
apparently is that um Panama's
government signed a deal with a Canadian
company giving them 20 years worth of
Mining rights whatever the motivation is
uh this is clearly putting people's
lives in danger the blockade ades when
more than 100,000 medical appointments
are being missed and businesses are
suffering $80 million in losses per day
then you're engaging in a violent
protest there's no other way to frame it
when people Miss medical appointments
they tend to get sicker some of them
might die on top of that store owners
who lose money every day are going to be
forced to make up that Revenue in some
other way which might expose them to
personal risk that we can't possibly
account for this is what happens when
the rule of law breaks down it's why the
rule of law is so important you know the
are coming up fast and uh while you're
out shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with rough
greens naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of rough greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
rough greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green so let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life Ru greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals prob biotics Omega oils
digestive enzymes and antioxidants that
your dog needs you don't have to go out
and buy new dog food just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr
Dennis black is so confident Ruff greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a free jump trial
bag so your dog can try it get a free
jump start trial bag delivered straight
to your door in just a few business days
go to Ru greens.com
matat or call 844 ru700 that's Ruff
greens.com or call 844 ru700 today but
for whatever reason authorities in
Panama never did clear this blockade at
any point in the past three weeks they
allowed these protesters to prevent
people from accessing Medical Care from
getting to their jobs from getting
anywhere else they wanted to go what
happened next well on Tuesday a
77-year-old man named Kenneth Darlington
who's apparently Amer an American lawyer
he has a dual
citizenship he approached the blockade
got out of his car and then he shot two
of the climate protesters and killed
them here's a
[Music]
clip
so we're not g to there you go he pulls
the gun out we're not going to show when
he actually fires the bullet um now
there are a bunch of news reports but he
does eventually he he ends up shooting
two them now there are a bunch of news
reports describing Kenneth darlington's
actions as horrific and quote unquote
shocking New York Post for example had
this headline about the incident
American lawyer 77 busted in Panama
after gunning down two Eco protesters
blocking Highway in shocking video
that's not really true yes he did gun
down to Eco protesters but there's
nothing shocking about it if you've been
paying attention now what he did is
obviously wrong it's murder plain and
simple cannot be condoned but shocking
No in fact the only thing really
surprising about Kenneth darlington's
reaction is that he's the first person
to react this way in the face of an of a
completely unreasonable sustained
blockade of a road that thousands of
people depend on for their
livelihoods we've seen suggestions that
people have had enough of this kind of
thing to be sure a few weeks ago for
example a tribal cop in Nevada plowed
through one of these climate blockades
made some arrests didn't harm
anybody um and for a very long time
leftwing protesters have been doing this
kind of thing they've been harassing ACC
costing intentionally inconveniencing
and interfering with normal people
trying to go about their
day and even if it is just an you know
you hear that sometimes as a defense of
these people that are in the highways
well it's just an inconvenience to
you well as we just as we covered often
times it's a lot more more than an
inconvenience but even if it is just an
inconvenience who who says that you can
deliberately cause a massive
inconvenience for anybody you want to
and if you do that eventually you might
get a reaction that you don't
want you can't just expect it you can't
just expect that everybody you can just
walk out there and inconvenience
everybody just for the sake of it and
they're all going to put up with
it um but we know they've obstructed
ambulances other emergency vehicles
they've vandalized and destroyed they've
intentionally added stress hostility and
ugliness to the world now to be clear
nothing I'm saying is intended to
endorse darlington's actions the point
here is not to encourage anyone else to
respond the way he did I wish this
hadn't happened I wish those people were
never in the road to begin with I wish
that when Darlington pulled that gun
they responded like sane people and
realized they'd pushed this man too far
and simply gotten out of the road where
they had no right to be in the first
place that's what makes if there's
anything shocking in the video actually
it's that he pulls the video he pulls
that gun out and points it at them and
they still stand
there um even with the gun out they
don't get out of the
road so I wish it had played out
differently but it
didn't instead what I'm saying is that
it was always inevitable that something
like this would happen eventually the
ruling class can only suspend law
enforcement for so long and so
arbitrarily until a Kenneth Darlington
appears and takes matters into his own
hands and now that this precise scenario
has happened I'm betting it won't be the
last time people are increasingly Fed Up
and
exhausted even the response to this
incident on social media shows that
these leftist protesters are
intentionally pushing people to the
brink and regardless of your politics
you can hopefully agree that's not a
smart thing to do it's a especially dumb
thing to do on a highway road rage
incidents pretty common all over the
world people get stressed out in traffic
unreasonably so often they lash out and
do drastic things this why it's a really
bad idea to you know flip somebody off
in traffic because you're mad that they
cut you off or whatever you don't know
who's in that car you don't know what
kind of day they're having you don't
know what kind of Life they're
having you don't know how on on edge how
Fed Up how completely and totally done
with your bull they might possibly be
now that's not to say that that you
deserve to have them pull up beside you
and open
fire you don't deserve to be killed for
waving your middle finger
around but if that's the response you
get it can't be denied that you could
have easily avoided it by making better
choices in the
moment and now imagine blocking an
entire Road full of traffic and
effectively giving the middle finger to
hundreds of stressed out commuters all
at once who are just trying to get home
from work or get to wherever else
they're going you are asking for
trouble there's an image of Kenneth
Darlington making the rounds on social
media became an instantly famous picture
um which you can see here and you can
see that Darlington you know he's
standing there pointing the gun uh and
and they got the shot I guess right
after he fired it somehow it's a
fascinating picture in many ways the
picture is worth a thousand words as
they say and most interesting thing
about it is darlington's expression he's
not screaming he doesn't look enraged he
doesn't have the expression of a man who
has gone totally
insane instead he just looks exhausted
looks tied Looks Like A Man simply fed
up there are a lot of people like that
in the world today people who just want
to live their lives and yet they find
every step of the way forces
intentionally trying to make their lives
worse and more
difficult people who have watched the
total breakdown of Law and Order and who
have been pushed to the brink and over
it because of all this again that's not
an endorsement of darlington's actions
it's just an observation about the state
of the world
uh and it's a state that maybe this is
most important to understand it's a
state that has been engineered by the
people in charge whether in Panama or
the UK or this country the authorities
take this lacad isical overly tolerant
approach to left-wing protesters engaged
in these kinds of disruptions or doing
things even worse than blocking traffic
or groups of people looting and you know
committing crime in the street and that
sort of thing this is happen happening
all over the place while the people in
charge just sort of Stand By and
Watch now if they wanted to protect
human life and preserve
order and prevent outcomes like this you
think they'd crack down on all this
stuff people blocking highways
vandalizing artwork vandalizing statues
looting Etc you think they'd make sure
the Pan-American Highway wasn't shut
down for the better part of the month
but the authorities are not doing any of
that which can only lead you to the
conclusion that they don't want to
preserve order at
all hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there